In the world...
In the world. The world. The world.
Turn off your phone. Somehow it binds us.
The trailer has four basic elements.
Storyline, characters, conflict and cliffhanger.
Each trailer is actually a short story that has footage from one movie.
The only difference between a trailer and a short story is a cliffhanger.
The aim of the trailer is to get people to the movies.
Cliffhanger is what's missing in the trailer.
The part you can enjoy by buying a ticket and watching the movie.
But how to make a trailer so good that the movie itself cannot be a flop?
Wait. Safety first.
Let's look at the history of the trailer structure
and why even today there are greasy trailers.
From the 1950s on, they had narrator trailers who told us four basic elements.
He described the characters, the conflict, the storyline and why it is worth seeing the film.
The story of little Tim and others in this unforgettable story ...
Clips from the movie only complement the narrative.
For most of the film history, the trailer was just a movie praising.
Describe the characters, the conflict, why we should go about it and show some shots.
And maybe throw funny music in a comedy case
or something epic in the case of drama.
Some trailers of this time were great.
Hitchcock spoke on Psycha while he was walking around Bates's motel.
The most terrifying events took place in this house.
How trailers have been shortened to fit into a pause
all started to look the same. Imagine the trailer "In the world ..."
The narrator tells us the characters, the storyline, the conflict and the cliffhanger.
New York cop John McClane came to his wife.
You missed me.
It's not just for action movies, comedies work similarly.
Tell us everything and throw some jokes.
Her name is Samatha Baker and she celebrates her 16th birthday today.
But then this format began to be predictable and boring.
Trailer type "In the world ..." is parodied more than it is used.
In a world where laughter was king ...
No "In the World", Jack.
Beware of excessive generalization
most of the films went by this formula,
but there were always trailers that stood out.
- We need to talk? - What? - Harry was here. - I was at Sally.
- I was upset. - The word has spoken.
- Then we kissed. - And to shorten it. - We did it. - They did it!
Finally, even ordinary trailers started to be more creative and especially effective.
A short trailer story can take about two minutes.
If you can say more in less time, cool!
First, get rid of the narrator and engage the characters in the movie.
This change makes sense.
If we use the characters' voice, we can imagine conflict, plot and characters at the same time.
Using science I'll put Mars on my ass.
Characters do not need to describe the cliffhanger, show it.
We want lightsabers if we go to Star Wars.
How to make a trailer? Challenge us.
End the trailer just before the impact of the lightsaber.
Trailer broadcasts a message. If you buy a ticket, you'll see this.
Then there is a trailer construction.
Start with something familiar, normal, and then break it.
- Does it live on African plains? - No.
Accelerate, increase volume, and then add climax and solution.
Many older trailers didn't do this, but today it's basically a norm.
But there is a buried dog. These techniques are so common
that makes the trailer stand out.
We are familiar with vague dialogues, exaggerated music.
For example, the last sentence of a trailer to be epic,
but it is so vague that it almost makes no sense.
When I saw you, I believed it was a sign
that something new may come to this world.
One way to fight this monotony is to make unique trailers,
where the main elements reveal the order of shots
instead of telling us the conflict and storyline.
With the right shots in the right order, we are able to see the plot and the conflict.
In the American sniper trailer Chris Kyle targets a child
she might have to shoot.
And his inner conflict? He doesn't describe any voice
but the order of shots.
And the cliffhanger is if he squeezes the trigger.
Maybe show us the scene between the two main characters
and alternate scenes as they talk, and those where they are in their costumes.
I have had a bad experience with the clown costume freaks.
Or show one whole scene from the movie.
Not a shot after the shot and no crazy background music
just a quality scene. You get a quality trailer.
That's why the Fast and Furious 7 trailer was successful.
Movie trailers are like car ads.
Most ads are basically the same.
Show us the car that drives around while the narrator picks up the car.
Stop the car, say its name and show the logo.
This type of advertising sells cars because it is still in use.
But he's boring. Maybe it's cheaper and easy to write, but we all know it.
Unique, funny, different viral ads
they are the best because there is hype around them.
Perhaps most of the trailers will continue to follow one formula.
But the ones that stand out, the unique ones you want to share
and you want to talk to friends, it's worth it.
Translation: Xardass www.videacesky.cz